[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es ein superschnelles und megaleckeres Rezept!
Ich werde einen Zitronen-Mandel-Kuchen backen
ganz ohne Mehl.
Der ist supersaftig.
Die Zutaten habe ich persönlich immer da.
Vielleicht habt ihr sie auch gerade da
und backt diesen Kuchen einfach ganz schnell nach
und genießt ihn einfach nur noch.
Denn er ist wirklich der Hammer!
Das Ganze habe ich auch noch
in Schokoladenvariante gemacht.
Und ich persönlich kann mich nicht entscheiden,
was besser ist.
Das könnt ihr ja dann entscheiden.
Also heute gibt es den Zitronen-Mandel-Kuchen.
Hier habe ich die Zutaten.
Ich brauche dafür
vier Eiweiß,
120 Gramm Zucker,
eine Prise Salz,
vier Eigelb,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
90 Gramm Butter,
220 Gramm Mandeln,
einen halben Teelöffel Backpulver,
eine Zitrone
und 70 Gramm gehobelte Mandeln.
Die Zitrone ist bio und ungespritzt.
Das heißt, ich kann die Schale verwenden
und aber auch den Saft.
Okay.
Das Erste, was ich jetzt machen werde, ist
der Eischnee.
Ich werde jetzt also Eiweiß
in eine saubere, fettfreie Schüssel geben
mit etwas Salz, weil es die Eiweißstruktur schneller zerstört,
und kurz steifschlagen.
[Musik]
Und, sobald der Eischnee fast steif ist,
kommt jetzt hier die Hälfte des Zuckers dazu.
Einfach nach und nach dazu geben.
So flockt der Eischnee nicht
und lässt sich auch gleich besser unterheben.
Und dann einfach noch mal weiter rühren.
[Musik]
Perfekt!
Guckt mal.
Der muss jetzt nicht ganz steif sein.
So passt es perfekt.
Als Nächstes
– ich tausche einfach hier kurz die Schüsseln.
Als Nächstes kann ich jetzt hier in einer zweiten Schüssel
die Eigelbe,
den restlichen Zucker
und etwas Vanilleextrakt verrühren.
Auch richtig schön schaumig rühren.
[Musik]
Hier drüben kann ich schon mal die Butter schmelzen.
So sieht die Masse jetzt aus,
weißcremig.
Jetzt gehe ich hier rüber
und kann nämlich die Mandeln direkt hierein zerkleinern.
Also ich habe jetzt hier geschälte Mandeln,
damit der Kuchen auch schön hell bleibt.
Ihr könnt aber natürlich auch
Mandeln mit Schale nehmen
und auch schon gemahlene Mandeln nehmen.
Ich habe aber immer nur ganze da
und zerkleinere sie selber.
[Musik]
Dann kommt hier jetzt der Abrieb der Zitrone rein.
Ich nehme jetzt den ganzen Abrieb.
Denn ich will, dass es wirklich schön nach Zitrone schmeckt.
[Musik]
Jetzt auch noch den Saft dazu geben.
Das Ganze könnt ihr auch gerne abwandeln
und mit einer Orange machen zum Beispiel.
Dann habt ihr einen Mandel-Orangen-Kuchen.
[Musik]
Jetzt nehme ich hier noch die flüssige Butter
und kann das jetzt auch schön einrühren.
[Musik]
Das Backpulver nicht vergessen!
Hätte ich jetzt fast vergessen.
Das wollte ich eigentlich
mit den Mandeln nämlich dazu geben.
Aber ist nicht schlimm.
Und jetzt hebe ich einfach nur noch den Eischnee unter.
Wie gesagt, ist der so ein bisschen
schlotzig,
nicht ganz steif.
[Musik]
Perfekt!
Und hier könnt ihr statt gemahlenen Mandeln
auch Kokosraspeln nehmen oder Haselnüsse.
Wobei, Haselnüsse finde ich jetzt nicht so gut
zur Zitrone passend.
Ihr könnt auch Mehl nehmen, wenn ihr keine Mandeln habt.
Aber das soll ja jetzt ein mehlfreier, glutenfreier Kuchen sein.
Ich habe jetzt hier meine Backform bereits gerichtet.
Und zwar nehme ich einen Tortenring.
Den habe ich auf 24 cm Durchmesser eingestellt.
Und ich schlage ihn jetzt noch ein,
damit einfach nichts ausläuft,
weil es doch ein recht flüssiger Teig ist.
[Musik]
Und so kann ich den Teig jetzt hierein füllen
Hier jetzt schön glatt streichen
und einfach noch mit den Mandeln bestreuen.
Und dann kann er in den Backofen,
wird gebacken, bis er durch ist,
und danach probieren wir ihn.
Also echt superschnell und einfach!
[Musik]
Der Kuchen ist fertig.
Ich habe ihn jetzt auch gerade mit Glitzerschnee bestreut.
Und er ist auch abgekühlt.
Und guckt einmal, wie schön der aussieht!
Schön flach gebacken.
Kein Hubbel.
Sarah holt jetzt gerade schon einen Teller
und eine Gabel zum Probieren!
She is the Dancing Queen!
Young and sweet,
only seventeen!
>> SARAH: Ja, fast
17.
Nehmen wir 17.
>> SALLY: Ich 29, du 17.
>> SARAH: Kommt hin.
So. Ich probiere das jetzt.
Soll ich?
Ja, oder?
>> SALLY: Dann wäre ich ja zwölf Jahre älter als du.
Wir sind beide 17.
>> SARAH: Können wir uns auf 18 einigen?
>> SALLY: Okay.
Dann können wir zumindest Auto fahren.
>> SARAH: Ja.
Dann dürfen wir wenigstens alleine Auto fahren.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Ohne Papa oder Mama.
Und los!
>> SARAH: Mmh!
Der ist ohne Mehl?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Krass!
Was hast du dann statt Mehl genommen?
>> SALLY: Mandeln.
Ja.
>> SARAH: Das schmeckt man aber gar nicht,
dass kein Mehl drin ist.
>> SALLY: Finde ich auch.
>> SARAH: Richtig gut!
>> SALLY: Megasaftig.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Der bleibt auch mehrere Tage saftig.
Mich erinnert der tatsächlich geschmacklich
ein bisschen an Grießkuchen,
weil die Konsistenz so...
Und es gibt im Türkischen einen Grießkuchen,
Revani Tatlısı.
>> SARAH: Ja, den kenne ich.
>> SALLY: Und an den erinnert der mich.
Aber echt voll lecker!
Und ich finde...
>> SARAH: Nee, das schmeckt echt richtig gut.
>> SALLY: Und nicht süß, nicht?
Nicht zu süß.
Ich finde es echt gut.
>> SARAH: Aber auch richtig weich. Seht ihr das?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Nee, das sieht man nicht, weil der Kuchen davorsteht.
>> SARAH: Er ist sehr weich.
Jetzt wollte ich auch mal was zeigen in der Kamera.
>> SALLY: Ja. Komm, zeige.
>> SARAH: Hier.
>> SALLY: Schön!
>> SARAH: Richtig schön...
>> SALLY: ... den Kuchen zerdrückt.
>> JOSH: Ich dachte auch gerade so: "Uh."
>> SARAH: Richtig schön weich.
>> SALLY: Ja, schön!
Schön.
Kannst du das noch mal zeigen?
>> SARAH: Soll ich es mit dem ganzen Stück?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Nee.
>> SALLY: Da. Das darfst du nehmen.
>> SARAH: Danke!
>> SALLY: Also, wenn ihr das Rezept nachmachen wollt,
probiert es mal aus.
In meiner App steht es auch noch mal
und auf meinem Blog
könnt ihr es gerne nachlesen.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich noch sagen soll.
Es ist halt supereinfach, schnell gemacht
und ohne Mehl.
>> SARAH: Glutenfrei.
Oder?
>> SALLY: Glutenfrei. Definitiv glutenfrei.
Ja.
>> SARAH: Für alle, die kein Gluten vertragen.
>> SALLY: Genau.
Und wenn ihr jetzt fragt:
Was könnt ihr statt Mandeln nehmen?
Wie gesagt, Haselnüsse,
Kokosraspeln.
Oder, wenn ihr Mehl dahabt,
ihr könnt auch gerne Mehl nehmen.
Aber dann ist es halt ein normaler Zitronenkuchen.
Also
dann ist eigentlich der Sinn dahinter weg.
>> SARAH: Ja, eben.
>> SALLY: Also viel Spaß beim Nachbacken!
Bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüss!
>> SARAH: Tschüss!
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Du hast die Mütze von Samira!
Sie sah dann auch immer aus
wie so eine peruanische Panflötenspielerin!
>> MURAT: Ela!
>> SALLY: Los! Gehst du ein Picknick machen?
Och, Schatz!
Hast du alles alleine getragen?
Boah!
>> ELA: Oma hat mir geholfen, die Tür aufzumachen.
>> SALLY: Super! Viel Spaß beim Picknick!
>> MURAT: Du musst lernen! Hausaufgaben machen!